[Music]  phishing scams they are on the rise  during the pandemic criminals looking to  cash in on people down on their luck  the company akamai technologies recently  uncovered a fake new york unemployment  website  scammarder sent a text or email  directing jobless workers to their site  and after a username and password were  entered  the fake site then asked for the  mother's maiden name and pin number  well once that information was entered  users were actually sent to a real new  york page  not realizing what had occurred do  people who enter in their  personal information on these fake sites  even realize that they've been scammed  no they do not by the time the scam is  over in fact it forwards you to the real  domain  and you'll never notice last year the  fbi received almost  a quarter of a million complaints about  phishing scams with people losing  a total of 54 million one way to spot a  fake site  is to double check the url